[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدي
الكرام الم يتعرض العلويون في سوريا لاكبر
حرب اباده في تاريخهم في ظل حكم عائله
علويه تصيح ديما سعد الله
ونوس الم يتجاوز ضحايا الطائفه ال 100 ال
قتيل كم قتيل خسر ال الاسد من عائلتهم ولا
واحد الم تتضخم ثروه العائله والمحيطين
بها بينما يتحول علويو سوريا الى طائفه
بلا رجال يضيف
اخر هل يعقل ان تفنى طائفه بكاملها من اجل
بقاء عائله لماذا يفاوض بشار الاسد على
الافراج عن الايرانيين والراهبات بين بين
ما يقبع مئات الضباط والابرياء العلويين
في سجون
المعارضه لماذا اصبح العلوي رخيصا الى هذا
الحد في بورصه الاسد يصيح اكثر من عيسى
لماذا يؤيدون او يؤيد العلويون عائله
زائله بينما يعادون اكثر من 20 مليون سوري
هل ما زال العلويون والدروز والمسيحيون
خائفين على مستقبلهم بعد ان عرفوا ان
النظام وحلفائه هم هم من صنعوا جماعات
القتل والارهاب وقطع الرؤوس لتخويف الداخل
والخارج
بها لكن في المقابل اليس من الاجحاف اتهام
ال الاسد بانهم يستخدمون العلويين قرابين
ووقودا للبقاء في السلطه اليس من الظلم
القول ان او انهم مستعدون للتضحيه باخر
علوي من قال ذلك اليست النسبه الاكبر من
مؤيدي النظام من السنه الا ترون كيف
يتسابق ال مقداد والزعبي وحسون على على
الدفاع عن النظام الوطني اليس من الخطا
اتهام ال الاسد بانهم ورط العلويين مع
بقيه الشعب السوري لعشرات السنين الم يحمي
سياده الرئيس السوريين جميعا من الارهاب
والارهابيين
والتكفيريين الم يزر السيد الرئيس قبل
ايام مخيما للاجئين العلويين في عذرا اليس
من الاجحاف اتهامه بانه لا يابه بالرهاب
العلويين من قال انه دق الاسافين و زرع
الاحقاد بين العلويين والسنه كي يموت
العلويين من اجله اليس هذا هراء اسئله
اطرحها على الهواء مباشره على السيد وحيد
صقر رئيس المكتب السياسي لتحرير سوريا
وعلى الاكاديميه دكتور وفيق ابراهيم نبدا
نقاش بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام
الكرام نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في
برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت
على موضوع هذه الحلقه هل تعتقد ان ال
الاسد يستخدمون العلويين وقودا للبقاء في
السلطه صوت حوالي
17500 شخص
93.6 نعم 6.4 لا وحيد صقر لو بدات معك
بهذه النتيجه اليس هناك من المبالغه يعني
ان ان نرى مثل هذه النتيجه فوق ال 90 93
94% من الشارع من العلويين يعتبرون ان ال
الاسد يتاجرون بالعلويين يستخدمون علويين
قرابين ووقود فقط من اجل تبقى هذه العائله
في السلطه حتى لو مات العلويون تحيه لك
ومشاهدين الكرام فقط بدايه دعني اترحم على
شهداء الثوره السوريه واليوم الذكرى
الثالثه لمرور الثوره السوريه وخاصه شهداء
درعا التي كانت شعله الثوره بالعوده الى
سؤالك بكل تاكيد انا متاكد تماما ان العدد
الذي لم يصوت على انه العلويين هم يتخذهم
الاسد وقود هؤلاء هم من محبي الاسد هؤلاء
هم المجموعه التي صوتت بعكس التصويت
الحقيقي هؤلاء بكل تاكيد نحن في الطائفه
العلويه وقلتها منذ خمس سنوات نحن
استخدمنا حافظ الاسد كوقود للوصول الى
السلطه والان بشار اسد يتخذ الطائفه
العلويه في هاويه لا تحمد عقباها لا احد
يستطيع حافظ الاسد طلع على ظهركم يعني
حافظ الاسد طلع على ظهر العلويين وبعد ما
وصل على الحكم ترك العلويين والتفت على
السنه وعلى تجار دمشق وتجار حلب وما ادراك
والعالم كله والتاريخ يعرف ه هل تعلم انه
اكثر من 70% من قر العلويين لا يوجد بهم
صرف صحي سوريا انتم موهومين اذا تتوقعون
ان العلويين هم في رفاهيه افقر شعب في
سوريا هو الطائفه العلويه هناك 10% من
الطائفه العلويه الذي استطاع حافظ الاسد
ان ياتي بهم الى الجيش والى الامن وان
يسحق المرجعيات الدينيه ويستبدل المرجعيات
الدينيه بهؤلاء الضباط هؤلاء الوحيدين
الذين يمثلون هؤلاء الذين صوتوا له الان
هؤلاء الذين صوتوا له واين هم الان هم
الان كلهم خارج سوريا هل تستطيع ان تقول
لي ان هناك احد من بيت شارش ولا من بيت
دوبه ولا من بيت فياض ولا من بيت ابراهيم
الصافي ولا من بيت الخياط هول الناس
الكبار حدا منهم اولادهم قتل حدا منهم
كلياتهم صاروا اولادهم برا نحن عم ندفع
الثمن لمين لبقاء مين سوريا انتهت يا
جماعه يعني انا صرت صارخ مليون صرخه
للطائفه العلويه نحن بحاجه الى وعي الى
صحو الضمير الشعب السوري يقتل سوريا تفتت
العقد الاجتماعي انتهى لم نشعر بالطائف
الا بعد ان اتى هذا النظام الى متى سيقتل
بشار الاسد بنا بشار الاسد ليس صاحب قر
يقتل طبعا ل يبعث اولادنا الى القتل ا يبع
هو عم يبعثنا اولادك العلويين قصدك طبعا
هو عم يبعثنا على الجبهه هو عم يقاتل
كرمان مشروع ايراني صفوي هو ضحيه فيه ونحن
العالين لازم نفيق لازم نصحى لازم نعرف
انه نحن من المستحيل ان نقبل باستمرار هذه
المهزله يا جماعه الا يوجد عقلاء بالطائف
العلويه في الداخل ان يقولوا كلمه حق يعني
لا يوجد نشاز الا وحيد صقر هناك مئات من
من الذين يتصلون معي لكن لا يتجرؤون على
الكلام انا على صله باكثر من 100 ضابط من
الطائفه العلويه اتمنى ان يكون بهم شخص
يستطيع ان يطلق رصاصه الرحمه لانقاذ
الطائفه هذا النظام لا يستطيع ان ينقذ
الطائفه هذه عصابه تحكم سوريا والذي يقول
عليها نظام هو غبي جدا وساد جدا هذه عصابه
متمثله ببيت مخلوف وببيت الاسد حكموا
سوريا 50 سنه وسيعود بسوريا الى 50 سنه
الى وراء لذلك علينا ان نكون عقلاء حقيقه
ان كنا نعتبر نفسنا نحن سوريين والا سياتي
يوم نهجر كما يهجر الان اخوتنا السوريين
الذين يهجرون الان السنه اليسوا اليسوا
سوريين سياتي يوم يهجرون لماذا لانكم
تدافعون عن بشار الاسد ماذا ستقول للاخرين
بعد رحيل بشار الاسد يعني يلي بيتوقع انه
بشار الاسد رح يستمر 100 سنه بالحكم بيكون
سادجورو
هذا للعلويين انا لا اكرههم انا علوي
وافتخر انني علوي انا ادافع عنهم اريدهم
ان يصحوا قبل فوات الاوان اريد ان تكون
هناك صحوه ضمير حقيقيه يا اخي والله الشعب
السوري مطافي سق تماما لو غير هذا الشخص
غير هذا الشخص علوي بالحكم الشعب السوري
سيصوت له لن يكون قول له الشعب السوري ليس
طائفي الشعب السوري كره العلويين من ورا
العائله هي كره الطائفه كلها ورح ندفع ثمل
ل 50 سنه لقدام طيب ليش ندفع ثمل نحن طيب
جم سؤال دكتور نعم كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
يعني البعض يقول الان يعني بدات الاصوات
ترتفع داخل سوريا داخل العلويين انه يا
اخي اين تذهب بنا يا بشار الاسد يا ال
الاسد هل يعقل ان تضحي بطائف باكملها تشكل
12% من الشعب السوري من اجل ان تبقى انت
وال مخلوف قال شاليش والال كذا تنهبون
البلد وتسرق البلد هكذا يقولون يعني مش
كلامي كيف ترد عليه انا الحقيقه اي انا
اعتقد وبموجب يعني قراءتي التاريخيه ويسف
لي ان اسمع هذا الكلام لانه انا عامل
اطروحه الدكتوراه عن نظام السياسي السوري
من ال 47 لى 70 جميل انا اقول لك ان سوريا
المدنيه التي ابتدات من 47 ل 58 هي سوريا
الاقطاع وبقايا الدوله
العثمانيه بعد ابتدا الخط القومي بالتبلور
استفادت كل الريف السوري الدروز والعلويين
والسنه والمسيحيين استفادوا من مسالتين
مجانيه التعليم والضباب المجانيه فتك فدخل
وانت تعرف ان ان ابناء التجار وسكان المدن
لا يلتحقون بالجيش الذي يلتحق بالجيش هم
فقراء الريف لذلك
تشكل تشكل في اطار جيش سوري ابناء درع
وابناء حمه وابناء الرقه وابناء جمال
العرب وا ابناء المناطق الشماليه فتشكل
هذا الكم كبير من الجيش السوري الذين هم
اولاد الفقراء الذين تقول عنهم انهم ان
الاسد يضحي بهم يدافعون اليوم عنك وعن
سوريا وعن كل السوريين هؤلاء يا سيدي عليك
عليك ان تسمعني جيدا حاظ العلويون يدافعون
عن سوريا وكل السوريين العلويون والسنه كل
الجيش السوري الجيش السوري بكل تكويناته
هو جيش غير طائفي هذا الجيش يقاتل عن كل
سوريا بما فيه العلويين اما على القتلى
فهناك قتلى من السنه اكثر من العلويين
هناك قتلى من الدروز هناك قتلى من
المسيحيين اما ال الذي يقتل فهو الذي اردى
900 علوي في شمال سوريا ذبحا على الهويه
النساء والاطفال في عذر العماليه تتكلم
هناك خط تكفيري يجتاح العالم العربي
والاسلامي هجم نيويورك هجم روسيا هجم
الهند هجم الصين الغى علاقات كل المسلمين
بكل العالم هذا الخط هو الذي يمر سوريا
اليوم وليس العلويين العلويون خليه خ
العلويون اليوم لا علاقه لهم بما يجري هم
جزء هم جزء من فصيل كبير يعني علاقه له
علاقه مش بالعمل الطائفي العلويون لا
يختلفون اعمال طائفيه ولا السنه هناك فقط
هذه الاحزاب التكفيريه الاصوليه التي اتت
والسوط السوريه هي التي تتبع على الهويه
انا اقول لك شيئا ارتفع الطبقه الوسطى
السوريه هي الطبقه التي نشات منذ ايام
حافظ اسد حتى ايام بشار الاسد قبل ذلك يا
اخي انت تعرف ان مفهوم الدوله الوطنيه كما
قلت للاستاذ فيصل هو اي مواطن يستطيع ان
يصبح رئيس جمهوريه حافظ اسد اتى الى
السلطه بموازنات العلويين كان العلويون
على هامش التاريخ اتى بموازنات الجيش اتى
بموازنات الجيش السوري بشار الاسد اتى
بموازنات البعث شو عم بتحكي بتحكي حكي
العلويين اللي جاب حفظ اسد لا اسرائيل
جابته انت انت
اسرائيلي اسرايل جابته جولان واسرائيل
جابته هذا منطق هذا
تاريخ اسد باع جولان وقتل راح جديد
واطع خلينا ناخذ
نقطه تفضل ل انا اقول لك شيئا منذ حافظ
اسد حتى اليوم العلويون ليسوا هم الذين
اتوا ليس هناك عائله تحكم سوريا هناك شخص
اسمه بشار الاسد في طبقه حول منه متشكله
من حزب البعث متشكله اكيد في في في نفعي
بكل دول العالم مثلا انا اعطيك مثلا عن
دوله مجاوره لقطر لك يحر ارضن الملك من
العائله مجلس الشورى مجلس البيعه مجلس
الوزراء لك حتى امراء الولايات الاقتصاد
لك عم اعملها بالقياس فانظر انظر ال قياس
فقط لك هي دوله فيها بشار الاسد بشار
الاسد لم يعطى فرصه لكي يحكم بشكل
ديمقراطي هجم هجم على الفض خلينا بس بس
دكتور خلينا بس الكلمه وانا اقول لك شيئا
اللي معلوماتك بشار الاسد اضطر للالتحاق
بالحلف الايراني لانه عرف ان الامريكيين
سيهاجمون العراق ان اسرائيل ستهاجم ان
المقاومه اللبنانيه ابتدات بالقتال فدافع
عن سوريا بدعم المقاومه في العراق بس مش
خلينا نخرج عن الموضوع المضوع الموضوع
العلويون ضحيه بس فقط العلويون يا سيدي
ضحيه هذا الخط التكفيري الي كيف ترد انا
ارد بالحرف الواحد عندما يقول من ذبح ناس
في المدينه العماليه اقول له بدا الذبح
بالحول بالترمس من اتى الى عين البيضاء
عندما بداوا وجاؤوا الى عين البيضاء
وبداوا يقتلون الناس ويدعس على رؤوسهم من
هم اناي علويه العلويه التركيه علويه
تركيه الي ج
فبات
ل ليست ليست فبركات هذا واقع هذا واقع
خليني بس دقيقه حده خليني كمل بس اتفقنا
بدون مقاطعه خلينا نسمعها تفضل تفضل حافظ
اسد اتت به اسرائيل الى السلطه باع
الجولان واتى به اتت به الى السلطه وهو
انسحب من الجولان ومقابل ان يسحب قواته
ويعطي امن اسرائيل ومنذ عام 1974 حتى
تاريخه لم تطلق طلق على الحدود
الاسرائيليه ومنذ هذا ذلك التاريخ حتى
الان وهو ياخذ من روسيا كل سنه اربع مليار
دولار اسلحه هذه الاسلحه خزنها لهذا اليوم
هذا اليوم الذي يحمي بها امبراطوريته
ونظام عائلته هذا واقع علينا خلينا بموضوع
العلويين العلويين هم ضحيه هذا النظام هم
ضحيه هذا النظام وسكوتهم في المستقبل
القريب ممكن هذه اخر فرصه لهم سكوتهم
سيجعلهم يدفعون الثمن لا يستطيع احد في
الكون ان يحميهم لذلك عليهم ان يعودوا الى
الوطن من من من هؤلاء الذين قتل بشار خل
من من من هؤلاء الذين قتلت اولادهم
وانتهكت اعراضهم وشردت نسائهم العلويون
العلو لا النظام النظام ومن معه يا رجل
حتى شهر عش ما كان في طاقه في سوريا خليني
بموضوع العلويين العلويون هم ضحيه هذا
النظام وصبر وبقاءه ملتفين حول بشار اسد
سيجعلهم يدفعون الثمن غالي وانا اؤكد لك
للاسف الشديد للاسف الشديد انا كنت متمني
ان تقوم دمشق وان تنطف دمشق وان بقاء دمشق
صامطه هو ما اطال عمر النظام وهناك تجار
من دمشق ورجال اعمال من دمشق ومتم من دمشق
هم الذين يدعمون بقاء بشار اسد وهم الذين
يدعمونه اكثر مما تدعمه الطائفه الطائفه
ضحيه طيب جميل جدا انا بسالك دكتور اسالك
من مصادر من الساحل السوري من وسط الطائفه
السوريه الطائفه العلويه في سوريا يقولون
ان عدد القتلى وصل الى اكثر من 100000 من
السوريين من العلويين يحكون ذلك ا البعض
يتحدث عن ان الطائفه العلويه ستصبح طائفه
بلا رجال معظم رجالها قد قتلوا اه
والعلويون بداوا يتململون ا يتحدثون الان
الى متى مثلا عندما تسمع اي بنت يعني
مشهوره اللي هي بنت سعد الله ونوس اه تقول
لك يا سياده الرئيس يعني الى متى تستخدمنا
كما لو كنا اثاث بيت كما لو كنا من ملكك
الخاص كفاكم ذبحا للطائفه العلويه النساء
العلويات بالمئات بعش الالاف يلبسون
السواد الان فقدوا شبابهم الطائفه فقدت كل
شيء من اجل من من اجل رامي مخلوف يقول لك
من اجل بشار الاسد من اجل من اجل من اجل
الهلال الاسد ها هم ها الع ووين يسالون
الى متى يذهبون انت بدي اسالك هل يعقل من
من هذا العدد البسيط بموت 100000 يا رجل
اول شيء هذه الارقام منوين هذ الارقام
يعني فبركات اعلاميه العلويين خصر لغايه
اليوم 8000 6000 منهم قتلوا ذبحا على
الهويه الله 6 خليه خليه يكمل لانه رح في
ناس في علويين كثير عم يضحكوا على الكلام
الض بضح تفضل انا اقول لك اختراع الارقام
ليس هنا المساله المساله هل العلويون
يقاتلون من اجل نشر الفكر العلوي في سوريا
بسال عم بسالك هل هل بنذ الف عام هل انتسب
واحد الىو هذا الموضوع قتلوها قاله العلوي
الى التابوت والمسيح على بيروت هذا هو
الشعار السائد
اليوم دقيقه خ بس دقيقه بس دقيقه العلوي
الى عتابو هل تعلم في درعا في بدايه
الثوره في درعا القوا القبض اه عند كانت
الثوره بدون اي سلاح القوا القبض على
اشخاص تبين انهم من المخابرات العسكريه
علويون كان الشعار اللي اعطى لهم قولوا
انه العلويين من الذي بدا دق الخوازيق بين
العلويين وبقيه اطياف الشعب السوري هذا
النظام قال يعني لو لم ادق الخوازيق بين
العلويين والسنه وبقيه الشعب السوري
العلويون لن يق قاتل ضدي داير بالك
بالبيضه يا رجل وهن يطلعوا على الناس
ويقولوا اه علي ا علي قراد يا رجل ما
شفتهم هو يقول له علي هذا هذا رئيس بحب
طائفته وول رئيس بحب طائفته بدق خوازيق
بينه وبين كل الشعب السوري تضل علي تفضل
اسمحلي بس اولا كل ما نسمعه على محطات
التلفزه نحو 300 محطه تلفزه انما تثبتوا
ان هناك امرا مدبرا بدليل ان تركيا الت
احتلت 400 عام ام تقف اليوم مع المعارضه
السوريه مليون تركاني في سوريا ينظمون
انفسهم على اساس انهم مع تركيا خليني نكفي
ط انت تعرف يا يا استاذ فيصل ان العلويين
طائفه مقهوره منذ ايام العثمانيين هناك خط
مملوكي تركي عطل الوحده في المجتمعات
العربيه والاسلاميه باختراع فتاوى لانه
كان معادي الصفويين عم يحكي عنهم في ايران
فكانت النتيجه انه الاتراك اسسوا اسسوا
اسس الاتراك ل عداوه ل عداوه بين الشيعه
والسنه
طيب كل شيء له علا بالمخابرات لا اناقشه
لانه يحتمل الخطا
والصواب اقول لك شيئا بس فقط هذ الكلمه
حرام ان نحمل طائفه لا تزيد عن مليونين
ونص وزر ما يحدث في سوريا جدا وصل انا
اسالك بدي تعطيني ارقام وبدون نكرر نفسنا
الرجل عمكي حقائق قال لك غير صحيح انه
الطائفه تفنى من اجل عائله زائله هذا غير
صحيح عدد الارقام يقولون 100000 علوي قتل
انه الساحل اصبح كله يلبس سواد كل يوم
تاتي م عشرات الالاف من مئات الجثث عفوا
البلد يقول لك هذا الكلام غير صحيح عدد
العلويين الذين قتلوا حتى الان 8000 مش
هيك كيف بترد عليه رد عليهل انا يعني جاي
من المريخ انا جاي من جبلي انا من الطائفه
وبعرف هل تعلم انه هناك في ضيعه اسمك
الماخ جنب القرداحه وصلوا جسس لك ماقوا من
عائله من بيت خضراء وصلوا جسس لهناك فتحوا
التوابيت لاقوا فيه حجاره لك صفت حتى
الجسس اللي بعثوا لنا اياها اولادنا راحت
لك كرمال مين عم بقول لك في شهداء بسوريا
ب راحت مقابل مين والله لو انه ماتوا
هالشعب كرمال تحرير الجوران ل قلنا اهلا
وسهلا مع هيك بشار الاسد نحن اعتبرنا اخر
من يعلم يعني شفت لما تصرف هذك اليوم وعمل
المستحيل حتى فك 48 ايراني مقابل صفقه
ترضي ايران وامبارح لما فك الرهيبات وانا
بعرف تماما وانا على تواصل مع ناس بالويه
عندها سجناء علويين وطلبوا مني اتوصل انه
اذا في امكانيه ل نخل سب العلويين لك ما
حدا معبرنا العلويين نحن اخر من يعلم لك
حتى حتى اللبنانيين اذا انتبهت على اللواء
عباس مدير الامن اللبناني كيف كان راكد
كانه شيء عا انجاز لك انا كنت متمني نصر
الله ولا متمني النظام اللبناني ان كان في
نظام لبناني يطالب بسجناء
المحبوسين المسيحيين بسجون صناي وسجون بيت
الاسد لك هدول شو وين رايحين لك نحن نحن
ورقه تحرق لا من اجل بقاء هذا النظام نحن
العلويين يحرقون من اجل بقاء بشار الاسد
لماذا وهذ المشكله المشكله بس خليك
رجعلي الر غير اخي انا ضيعتي نفسها معروفه
ضيعتي نفسها في اكثر من 700 قتيل حتى الان
ضيعه فيها 3 الف واحد فيها 700 قتيل شو عم
تحكي انت في اكثر من 80 90 الف قتيل
بالطائف العلويه اكثر رجل ش شيء مرعب
ناهيك ناهيك عن عن التخويف انتبهوا اذا
حدا ممكن بيرفع راسه هيك عم نبون حتى الان
في في لجان شعبيه اسمها اللجان الوطني عم
تخوف الطائفه حتى الان ديروا بالكم اذا
بيسقط بشار لجوا يذبحو السنه هذا التجييش
الطائفي اللي على بيروت العلوي على بيروت
كله كذبك كذب لك يا اخي كل الحكي كذب شغل
م هذا لك هذا شغل النظام هذا شغل بشار
الاسد
ونظامه اخي يا جماعه فهموا لك شو قدم بشار
الاسد وحافظ اس للسوريين للعلويين شو قدم
ايام رفعه الاسد كان ياخذ الشب من عننا
بسور بسوريا عمره 16 سنه وياخذه علىكل على
سرايا الدفاع يقول له يرزه مرقه و 300
ورقه والسرايا مرايا لعن رب الطائفه
العلويه بيت الاسد بيت الاسد دمرونا هذا
قناعتنا وقناعه 90% من الطائفه العلويه بس
جبناء ليش جبناء ما بعرف هذا السؤال وحت
والان وط وحتى الان وحتى الان جب لي واحد
من هدول اللي عم بحكي لك عنهم جيب لي واحد
انه مااله مستفيد لك يا رجل نحن عم ندفع
ثمن لشو ما بعرف هذا السؤال نحن عم ندفع
ثمن لبقاء هذه العائله وهذه العائله بعد
ما النظام نست كل شي اسمه علوي والتفتت
للتجار والتفتت لتهريب الاموال والتفت
للمخدرات والتفت لفتح الحدود لك يا رجل
مليارات اشتروا بيت مخلوف وبيت الاخز
بلندن انا اب لندن وبعرف مليارات كلها
هربوه لبرا سرقوا الدم وسرقوا الماله وهلا
بكره مين يعني بكره يعني هلا اذا بس يعني
يعني اللي بفكر لساعه واحده انه بشار رح
يبقى ع سنين ثانيات بكون حمار ما بون بشار
بون حمار وه دنب ما هذا بشار ماشي هذا
النظام ماشي اذا بدكم تعملوا شي سرتكم
فعلا الويين يعملوا نداء مصالحه وطنيه مع
مع بقيه القوى لانقاذ سوريا وان يعني يعني
انت يعني انت تقول انه العلويين يعادون
العلويين يعادون 20 مليون سوري من اجل
عائله زائله هذا حكي مضبوط وهذا الواقع
هذا الواقع خايفين خايفين لانه العالم
غرقت بالدم وورط العالم بالدم تورطت
العالم بالدم تورطت بالدم وبال الاغتصاب
وبالقتل وبتهرب وذبح ويعني يعني يعني اذا
هو استقدم الايراني واستخدم التركي
واستخدم الشيعي وع زينب وباع كل القبيسيات
اليران وهلا نحن العلويين تحديدا ففهموا
نحن العلويين عباره عن وقود لمستقبل بين
حرب سنيه شيعيه نحن وبقيه الاقليات في
سوريا سندفع ثمن الاقليات طبعا مثل المسيح
والدروز انتم شركائنا طبعا انتم من
الخارجين طبعا طبعا نحن كفار واللي كفرنا
اكثر بقانا ورا ورا هال الرجل اللي عم
يستخدمنا يعني بشار الاسد ابوه قال بزمانه
كلمه لن يستقر النظام حتى طالما البلد
طالما الجبلين مستقرين كان يعني جبل
الدروز وجبل العلويين هذا كلمه مين كلمه
حافظ الاسد لن يستقر البلاد الا يستقر جبل
العلويين وجبل الدروز وطالما هؤلاء هذين
الجبلين لن يقوموا فانا مرتاح لذلك انا
اقول المشكله هلك نحن بنا وبكم نحن
العلويين ودروز يجب ان يكون لنا كلمه حق
نثبت اننا سوريين حقيقه ناهيك على انه انا
اال انت عم تقول للطوائف الاخرى يعني
شوفوا يا طوائف اخرى يا مسيحيه ودروز
واسماعيليه اذا ال الاسد باعوا العلويين
بتاع الطافه فانتم بده يشتروك يعني هيك
قصدك بهذا الواقع هيك معقول بكل تاكيد
يعني انت اذا باع العلويين ب يشتري يا اخي
باع باع سوريا يا رجل باع سوريا باع سوريا
سوريا لم تعد سوريا ان لم يكن هناك عقلاء
سور انا بدي احكيلك انت ت تعرف سعد الله
ونوس الكاتب المسرحي السوري الكبير من
الطائفه
ديما سعد الله ونوس اقرا لك سطرين فقط
بعنوان عم بتقول له نحن العلويين ليش بحبك
لبشار الاسد سياده الرئيس بشار حافظ الاسد
اليوم فقط تاكدت اننا كعلو مجرد ارقام لا
قيمه لنا في دولتكم فرحت لتحرير الراهبات
من قلبي واشكر المسلحين لعدم اشتراطهم
اعدام الف علوي مقابل الراهبات لم يعد لدي
شك انكم كنتم فكرتم بالامر اين علويو عذرا
اين علويات الساحل سيادتكم هم اكثر من 176
امراه وطفله شاهدتهم قبل ايام على
التلفزيون ناس لووا القلب علويين مساكين
نعم ام اننا بتنا لمسؤولي مجرد ارقام لا
قيمه لها هل نحن مملوكون لاشخاص لا نعرفهم
سيادتكم اخبرونا الحقيقه هل لديكم طاب
اخضر ورقه ملكيه بنا ك علويين نحن من دفع
ويدفع الثمن فخامه الرئيس اعذرني سياده
الرئيس الا ان سياستكم باتت تشكل خطرا
وجوديا حقيقيا على العلويين نحن بشر
سيادتكم لدينا احاسيس ونبكي ايضا صدقني
نحن كالجميع خلال تاريخ العلويين منذ
القرن الثالث الهجري ولغايه الساعه لم
يتعرض العلويون الى هكذا اباده ومن من من
دوله رئيسها علوي يعني العلويون بتاريخهم
ما تعرضوا للاباده كما يتعرضوا تحت ال
الاسد الان كيف ترد عليها هذه بنت بسعد
الله ونوس الله يقويه بس انا يعني الحقيقه
من خطابك ارد عليك هذا دليل على ان الرئيس
بشار الاسد لا يمارس سياسه علويه جميل
جميل بكل تاكيد انه يمارس سياسه عربيه
سوريه والعلويون جزء من هذه المنظومه
يدافع عنهم بمقدار دفاعه عن السنه وعن
الدروز وعن كل الناس الا اختراع يعني ما
يقوله الاستاذ انما يندرج في اطار اثاره
الفتنه السنيه الشيعيه و واطار واطار
اثاره الفتنه السنيه مع الاقليات في سوريا
انا اقول لك شيئا بشار حافظ اسد هو اول
علوي يحكم سوريا منذ 1ف عام المالكي هو
اول شيعي يصل الى السلطه في العراق منذ
ايام الحجاج بن يوسف يعني انا ابكي على
هذه مشاريع الدوله الوطنيه التي يضحكون
علينا بها ثم عندما يصل شخص اخر من مذهب
جاوبني على هذا ما تبعد كثير دكتور والله
كلامك كير مهم مهم ما مهم كلامي المهم انا
اقول لك بسهوله تستطيع ان تخترع
فتنه بسسرعه
تطيع وتحول تعب حق بس خليني لا لا دوون في
سوريا مظلومون اولا مظلومون الان يشتكون
من
انا بدي اسالك هو قال بالاول هل تستطيع ان
تذكر لي نعم كم شهيد بين قوسين طبعا مات
من ال الاسد او مخلوف او شاليش دقيقه
دقيقه دقيقه يقول لك العلويون الان مات من
العلويين اكثر من 100000 بس دقيقه بس
دقيقه اذا مات شي واحد من ال الاسد او ال
شليش ماذا يحدث الان ماذا يحدث بس خليني
اكمل لك السؤال بس الان ماذا يحدث رامي
مخلوف عاد الى واجه قال يريد ان يعيد
اعمار سوريا اكل سوريا عندما كانت سوريا
في في خيراتها والان بده يعيد اعماره تصور
يعني نهب سوريا في الماضي والان يعود الى
نهب يقول لك العلويون الان نحن فقراء هذه
العائله لا يهمها الا تعبئه جيوبها هربت
المليارات الى الخارج مليارات ولا لا هذا
العلويين يموتون وعائله تهرب مليارات الى
سوريا وهم يقولون كيف تقولون عليهم انا
اقول لك كل الانظمه العربيه من الخليج الى
المحيط ايه اسوا من النظام السوري يا اخي
ماشي ماشي بس انا عم بسالك عن النظام
السوري الان العلويون ليسوا متورطين
بمعركه مذهبيه العلويون هم جزء من النسيج
الوطني السوري صدف صدف ان ان لديهم في
الجيش عناصر كثيره باعتبار انهم فقراء
والفقراء ومعصب الجيوش في العالم كله اما
انا ساستعرض لك اسم 1ف رئيس دخلوا 1ف حرب
اعطيني واحد من عائلاتهم سقط شهيدا او سقط
قتيلا انتم تخترعون اي شيء فقط خلي في تضل
اولا انا ساقول لك سوريا انت عم تحكي على
حافظ اسد قلت عنه ان انه اسرائيل جابته
حافظ الاسد هو الرئيس العربي الوحد كلام
1973 حارب اسرائيل وتمكن الجيش السوري من
الوصول الى اعالي خليه يكفي ماشي بس بس بس
مشان باسم العلويين باسم السوريين ولولا
انحراف السادات لكنتم حرتم الجولان ماذا
تريد ان يصالح العرب لو حررنا
الجولان
اول شغله اربع دول عربيه استبت في اسرائيل
بقي حافظ اسد لسلم بشار
الاسد رسول الله هي هزم اسرائيل بال 2006
اما انت فتضحك
بسور وفيق خلص دورك جاوبني بدي اسالك سؤال
انا تفضل شو بك تحكيله
هذا الكلام اللي عم يحكيه بعيد كل البعد
عن الصحه حافظ اسد لم يقدم للطائفه
العلويه شيئا ابدا ابدا الا انه سيحملها
وذر كل هذه المرحله التي عاشها ماشي خليك
دق انت قلت قبل شوي بس خليني اكم خليني
اكمل لك يقال ذات يوم بدي اطرح عليك هذا
السؤال مثل ما طرحت على الرجل يقال انه
محافظ حماه ايام حافظ الاسد اه زار في في
الريف الحموي فوجد ان معظم قرى العلويين
فقيره لا فيها لا ماء ولا كهرباء ولا فيها
اي شيء ماشي فبدا الرجل يريد ان ياتي
بالكهرباء والماء والى ما هنالك والطرق
الى القرى العلويه ماشي فسمع حافظ اسد
بالمشروع فناد له الى دمشق لمحافظ قال له
تعال ذهب المحافظ الى دمشق فقال له حفظ
اسد شو شو يا زلمه سمعنا انه عم تعمل
مشاريع وكذا قال له ايه والله هال علويين
فقراء ومساكين قال له ولك يا غبي ولك اذا
بكره بعمل لهم للعلويين طرق وكهرباء ومي
بظل واحد منهم بالشاب بيقعد هون بالمعظمة
قدر استخدم الطائفه وقدر جيش الطائفه وقدر
خلى الطائفه تتمسك فيه وانا بعتبر حاليا
الطائفه مخطوفه كما غزه خطفت حماس وكما
الاخوان يا اخي بس انت عندما تر عندما ترى
هذه الجماعات اللي حكى لك عنها الدكتور
التكفيريه وخط التكفير
هول جاب امريكا بشار اسمعني امريكا وبشار
اسم بشار يقوم الان بحرب وان حكي قلته
بشار يقوم بالحرب بالوكاله الان عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الامريكيين
والحدود الجنوبيه بما فيها الاردن ولبنان
وتركيا سهلت دخول هؤلاء المتطرفين لكن ل
يخوف بهم
العلويين يخوف بهم العلويين والاقليات
ومنه حتى يخلصوا من حكم بشار بشار انتهى
هلا امامه دور يخلص من المتطرفين وبعدين
منتهي هو الان يقوم حرب الوكاله لذلك انا
ندائي ليس لا يعني انا ما يعني خليك دقيقه
بس خليني اسالك سؤال يعني تريد ان
تقول رؤوس وه الارهابيين صنعتهم المخابرات
السوريه مشان تخوف العلويين والاقليات
فيها رل يا رجل ه هول كانوا بالسجون
السوريه في منهم معظم قياداتهم كانت
بالسجون السوريه وانا على درايه كانوا
يدربوا في الزقيه وبعتو على العراق ورجعوا
من العراق وطابق السم لازم يذوق منه هدول
صناعه نفسهم بعدين لا صناعه النظام صناعه
هذا
النظام هل تعلم انه انه كان في هناك يد
لقتل ابن لادن مساعده النظام السوري وكان
هناك مساعده بين امريكا وبين النظام
السوري باحداثيات مقتل ابن لادن النظام
السوري اكبر خادم للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمشروع الدولي ولذلك الولايات
المتحده الان صار بشار بس كل ما يتضايق
ينادي له اوماما ما عاد ينادي اوباما لانه
مثل امه صار خلي خلي خليني بس خليني اجلي
النقطه هذه يا سيد وحيد يعني تريد ان تقول
انه يا طوائف يا اقليات بعد ان عرفتم الان
ان قاطعي الرؤوس والارهابيين جابلكم اياهم
بشار مشان يخ وف اصحوا يعني هيك قصدك هذا
الحكي ملنا ونحن نحكيه ملنا ونحن نحكيه
نحن بنطلب هلا من الطائف العلويه ومن كل
الاقليات ان تثبت انتمائها لسوريا كسوريا
وان تبحث عن عن خطوات حقيقيه يكون هناك
مصالحه وطنيه مع اهل الدم هناك دم من
الطرفين من الشعب السوري ومن الضحايا
الذين ذهبوا كرمال بقاء بيت الاسد يا اخي
انت عم تخلي اللي قطعوا الروؤس مرت سنه
ونص ما حدا انقطع راسه كان كله اللي يقطع
راسه بحوله قطعوا الروؤس 11 واحد بالحول
العلويين العلويين قطعوا راس جيرانهم
بالحول وبتمس
[موسيقى]
وببيضة ام اذا
بتلا اللون قائد الل اللواء خاف من
الملازم تركيبه مرعبه الملازم العلوي
ملازم العلوي طبعا لانه ضوابط امن والعميد
هو اللي هو قائد الفرقه بخاف منه تركيبه
مخيفه يعني دق الاسفين هي اختصاصه شق الصف
اختصاصه استغلال الفرفو تخويف العلويين
ولوف يا رجل هلا هارون الاسد وهلال الاسد
شو عم ي هارون الاسد وهلال الاسد هلا بال
شو عم ي ي صفوا المسيحيين وعم يطلبوا فديه
وعم يهربوا شيء مرعب هلال وهارون هلا هلا
هلا ناس من جبله خطفوها وقتلوها بعد ما
اخذوا الفده تبعها شيء مرعب يا زلمه هيك
خلص تجييش طبعا لك لك انا تمنيت مره طلبت
يضربوا القرداحه ما حدا ضربها ل خلوهم
يحسوا بوجع طيب هل ليس من المبالغه ان
تقول انه العلويين هم اول من سيهجم على
قبر حافظ الاسد في القرداحه اذا سقط
النظام اليس من المبالغه هذا الكلام والله
اتمنى لا مش مبالغه هذه والله اتمنى ان
يكون هناك صحوه ضمير حقيقيه واتمنى ان
يكون صحوه ضمير من احد الضباط تكون رصاصه
الرحمي لانقاذ الطائفه ان طلع لنا واحد
فعلا في شويه وطنيه بده يحمي ه الطائفه
يقتل بشار الاسد برصاصه هذهه تكون انقاذ
الطائفه وغير هيك ستهجر الطائفه الى 400
سنه لقدام والحرب القادمه حرب سنيه شيعيه
نحن وقودها العلويون والدروز والمسيحيون
والتركمان والاكراد كلياتنا بقول لهذه
الحرب هناك مد حقيقي وهناك مشروع صهي
ايراني امريكي برعايه امريكيه لتكون شرطي
اخر مع اسرائيل هي ايران واسرائيل جميل
جدا انا اسالك سؤال دكتور طيب هذا السؤال
يطرحه بعض عقلاء العلويين يقولون يا
اخي نحن مع بشار الاسد نحن مع هذه العائله
لانها تحمينا لان هكذا نحن مهددون
بالمتطرفين والارهابيين اللي حضرتك حكيت
عنهم ماشي طيب بس البعض يقول لك صحيح هذا
الكلام طيب الى متى سيبقى هذا النظام ال
مت الى متى سيبقى بشار الاسد ع سنوات 20
سنه 50 سنه طيب وبعد 50 سنه من سيحمي ايها
العلويون لماذا تعادوا 20 مليون سوري من
اجل عائله زائله عاجلا او اجلا طيب هذا
السؤال مش مطروح اذا بدك جاوبي اولا لقد
ادارك يعني كما اراد انت قلت امريكا حولك
ص على النظام السوري هي اول نقطه تل ثاني
نقطه وهي الاهم جاوبني على سؤال ان
العلويين كما قلت انت يؤمنون بالدوله لذلك
عندما يعتبرون ان بشار الاسد زائل يؤمنون
بالدوله ويعرفون ان السنه بعد هذه الاحقاد
وماذا عن الاحقا طيب لا بس دقيقه بس دقيقه
طيب يقول لك يا سيدي يا سيدي يقولون الان
انه بشار الاسد وعائله الاسد ورطت
العلويين في داوات تاريخيه مع السنه ل سنه
ل سنه خبره منكما ب موضوع الاسلام السني
السوري الاسلام السني السوري اسمه المرجئه
الذين ارجوا احكام الاسلام الى الله
المذهب التكفيري اليوم في سوريا ليس من
الاسلام السني السوري العلويون يضعون
امرهم بين ايدي اخوانهم السنه ويعرفون
انهم بعد ان هجروا 8 ملايين منهم ما هجروا
حدا مش ان هجروا تكين على العلويين الحرب
التكفيريون هم الذين هجروا انا بجب لك
مقالات بجريده اللوند الفرنسيه ان التهجير
كان عملا مقصودا وافكار النازحين كان عملا
مقصودا لاخذ بنيه مقاتله منهم رخيصه لك
استاذ فيصل علينا نحن العرب ان نقف اليوم
لنقول لكفى هذه الحدود المفتوحه 400 400
عام احتلو الاتراك لك المماليك قعدوا 400
سنه ل هؤلاء خلقوا انقسامات يعني بين
العرب وبين المسلمين اليوم العلويون
يضعون بس بس دكتور انا اريد ان استفيد من
خبرتك التاريخيه وانت استاذ كبير في
الاعلام وكذا اريد ان اقرا عليك ايضا كم
سطر من اكث من عيسى وهو من الشخصيات
العلويه الكبيره المعارضه ها يقول لك اكث
منن عيسى هل اعجب الطاغيه القابع في دمشق
بمنظر المخطوفين من النساء والاطفال حيث
تم عرضهم البارحه على قناه الجزيره هل
تفاجا بهم وبان هناك العشرات من العلويين
جلهم من الاطفال والنساء هم قيد الخطف منذ
اشهر مضت وهل ما زال يرى ان هؤلاء هم
عبيده الذين اورثهم له ولعائلته ابوه وان
لديه الكثير منهم ذكورا واناثا يكفو في
حربه المجرمه عاما او عامين اخرين في احسن
تقدير ويرى ان لا باس بطائف ان تجعله
ويستمر على كرسيه يعني الرجل يقول لك مرشح
كرسيك او كرسيك ورئاسته هل تفكر بشيء اخر
هل تفكر بالعلويين هل تف فرح لانك حولت
قسما كبيرا من طائفه الى وحوش فتاكه
مستغلا فقرهم وجوعهم وعواطفهم ابشع
استغلال طائفه عرفت بتسامح وانفتاحها
وطيبه اهلها صبرت على كل المحن واشدها
ظلمك وظلم ابيك من قبلك وسفاله سلالت كذا
كذا وجعلت من خيره شبابها حطبا لحربك
الشنيعه ضد شعب ليحصد الموت واحدا تلو
الاخر هناك اصوات داخل العائله يقولون
الان ايها العلويون نحن نموت من اجل عائله
ز
من سيحمي بعدها يا رجل انت بتطمن العلويين
الانو هناك خط وطنيا داخل سوريا هو اقوى
من الحركات التكفيريه لم يعبر عن نفسه بعد
وسيعبر واقول لك ان الدوله الوطنيه
السوريه ستعاود انطلاقتها قريبا
لي
لبنان بس دقيقه دكتور وفيق لماذا لا يخرج
الرهائن
العلويين
بالمئات ه نتحدا وبعد يومين يطلع بشك لانه
تتحدا بتحداك انك روح
طع انت بد مند انتم بدلا من ان تدينوا
الذين خطفوا لك عم اديله بشار الاسد يا
رجل خطفوا الرهد طلع حق بشار الاسد ل وقع
واحد طلع حزب الله حزب الله سيقاتل في
سوريا الى جانب السنه والى جانب النظام
تحكي
منق فلين اليوم حدثت عمليه تبشر بالخير عن
الحدود السوريه مع فلسطين المحتله سقط
ضابط اسرائيل يا اخي حرام عليكم انظروا
لهذا الواقع العربي المتدهور نحن نعود الى
القرون الوسطى انت اليوم يعني تمثل شكل من
اشكال القرون الوسطى حيي هذا الجبل العلوي
ليس على عليته بل على وطنيته ماشي جميل
جدا سؤ انا بسالك سؤال بالجال اخر انت
تقول انه طلع الراهبات اه وطلع الايرانيين
وانه حطيته وانتم المعارضه ما شاء الله
عليكم كاريكاتير انه الايراني ب 5000
المسيحيه ما بعرف كذا والعلوي بلاش ما
بتوفي معي انتم كتبتوه هذا الكاريكاتير
انه ح بشار الاسد قاعد وع قايض بالواحد
طيب بشار الاسد منذ ايام زار معسكرا او
مخيما للاجئين العلويين وطمنهم وقدم لهم
الكثير من التسهيلات في عذرا هل تستطيع ان
تنكر ذلك امبارح زارهم امبارح الزلمه
زارهم امبارح السيد الرئيس زارهم يا زلمه
واذا زار يعني شو المشكله واذا زار ش شو
المشكله يعني لك يا رجل عم اقول لك عم
اقول لك من يوم اللي اجوا هالعائله حكمه
سوريا لم تقدم للطائف شيء لا
تقدم الطائف شي يعني كل هذا الذهاب اللي
عم تحكي عنه عباره عن بروباجندا اعلاميه
ليكسب موقف داخلي فقط لا غير لكن على صعيد
الواقع هل فكر ان يفاوض بهؤلاء الذين
موجودين بجبه النصره ولا مع الحركات
الاسلاميه ولا مع الالويه طيب لماذا
يتركهم لانه لا يحتاجهم
صر الله ركد ورا سيد نصر الله انت مقولن
نصر الله نصر الله بنظرنا هو قاتل شعبنا
وهو
شرعن شي اسمعني شوي اخي من الشهر الثالث
من انطلاق الثوره كان علم حزب الله موجود
برا شو عم تخليه انت في تدخل من الشهر
الثال اسؤال يا
س سيد وحيد الان الان داعش داعش انسحبت من
الكثير من المناطق المحيطه باللاذقيه
بالساحل ماشي البعض بدا يتهم النظام انه
هو كان حططها هناك والان يريد ان يقدم على
مجازر بحق العلويين كي يجيش مره اخرى ضد
البقيه هل هذا معقول هل هذا
مع معلوماتي متاكد انا داعش هناك اكثر من
50% منها
مخابرات مخابرات جويه سوريه وانا متاكد
تماما واؤكد لك هناك مهمات ستقوم بها هذه
قلب ترك
جدا وهناك هذا الموضوع بخطه اسديه
تما خليني بموضوع سحب داعش من الساحل
السوري تمهيدا لمجازر بحق العلويين كي
يجيش مره
اخرم ولم ينسحبوا لوحدهم لم يكون هناك
تعليمات
بانسحاب في موضوع في هدول يخضعوا الى
قياده بالمخابرات الجويه في هناك ضابط
في هناك
رل اسمعني شوي والله انت انا بس بدي اسال
سؤال قبل ما اكملك الفكره انت عندك قناعه
بده يبقى بشار الاسد رس عندي قناعه يبقى ر
سيبقى بشار الاسد رئيسا للجمهوريه السوريه
حتى الانخابات
الم حتى الانتخابات المقبله والانتخابات
المقبله هي التي تقرر من هو الرئيس المقبل
لسوريا وصحتين على قلب بيرح الناس بس اقول
لك واللي ماتوا السيد حسن رسول
الله سي
حسنيي داعش تجيش طائفي حقيقي لاستقدام
وتخويف الساحل السوري بهم متى يريد هذا
اللي صار وهذا اللي صار هذا اللي صار انه
انتبهوا هي داعش انتبهوا بعدها بهالمرحله
هي انه انا هلا امنت لكم مشان يظلوا
متمسكين معه لكن باي لحظه ممكن يرجع ماشي
خليني اسالك عن موضوع التجييش هذا سؤال يا
سيدي يقول البعض انه اكثر من استخدم سلاح
التجييش وزرع الفتن الطائفيه داخل سوريا
هو هذا النظام اترك لي العلويين في
السويداء بين الدروز كان ياتي بالجنود
الدروز المخابرات العسكريه في السويده
وتقول لهم هذول السنه الارهابيين في درعه
بدهم ياكلوك في عندك واحد اسمه جامل
البلعاس المسؤول هذا مساعد اول هذا في
السويداء مخابرات عسكريه وعندما يذهب الى
درعا بيتحول الى جماعات ارهابيه بيلبس
افغاني وبيروح بيقتل هناك وبيخطرلي جامل
البلعاس هو وهذا الثاني تبع المخابرات
العسكريه طيب عم بقول لك الرجل اكثر من
زرع الاسفين داخل الشعب السوري هم النظام
بين العلويين وبين السنه بدي اسالك
بالبيضه داير بالك البيضه يوم بداوا يدعس
على الناس شو كانوا يقولوا شو كانوا
يقولوا يا علي وما بعرف شو طيب شو الهدف
منها الهدف يا علويين يا علويين ديروا
بال العلويين لا يشكلون عددا هاما في
سوريا العلويين انا انا سنه 79 كانوا
يشكلوا 15% من السكان اليوم رجعوا عم
تقوللي انت 10 وطلع في 20 مليون مع 3
مليون كردي ومليون تركماني وفي شي خ س
ملاي مصل تركي بسوريا المهم حبيبي انا
ساقول لك شيئا اخيرا طيب النظام السوري
اليوم العلويون لا يقاتلون في سوريا على
اساس تشكيلهم الديني انهم يشتركون في
سوريا في اطار مؤسسات الدوله السوريه التي
هي مؤسسات شرعيه الجيش السوري واحد منها
وهم قله في الجيش السوري 10% فقط يعني
الغلبه هي الطوائف السنيه اليوم في 400000
مقاتل بجيش 80% منهم سك قل لي كيف يقاتلون
مع الاسد هذا الاسد لانهم يعرفونه انه اسد
وانه لا حبد ما بيهمه ما بيهمه موضوع
علويين بيهمه موضوع سوريا فقط لذلك حافظ
اسد منع محافظ حماه انه انه يميز العلويين
غيره طيب باختصار بالوقت ده انا فقط انا
انا يعني انا الحلقه كلها الطائفه فيل
المتين الطائفه العلويه امام مسؤوليه
تاريخيه تجاه الشعب السوري امامك ايها
الطائفه العلويه مسؤوليه تاريخيه امام هذا
الشعب منذ بدايه الثوره حتى الان هناك اذا
3 مليون بيت اذا كل بيت راح تحت منه واحد
عندك 3 مليون قتيل في سوريا ماتوا بسبب
هذا النظام اذا نص واحد مو واحد راح مليون
واحد يعني عندك مليون ونص يعني هالناس هال
الضحايا اللي
راحت موضوع العلويين هي رساله للعلويين
هذه فرصه تاريخيه اذا فعي انا نداءات اكثر
من عيسه والثاني والثالث ما عاد تعني لي
النداءات كنت اول من من من تبنى بيان لكن
نريد مواقف حقيقيه ما بدنا البيان يعني
اكثر من عيس لما اعتقلوا لي زوجتي في 2009
لم يتجرا في سوريا ان ان يصدر قرار ان
يصدر بيان تنديد باعتقالها لانه علويه
يعني الموضوع المووضوع ما عاد يهمني
بيانات بيهمني موقف حقيقي من الطائفه
العلويه ان تحدد هي سوريه حقيقه ام هي
علويه وستذهب مع بشار اسد الى قم او الى
مكان يعني تريد ان تقول يا علويين بكره
بشار اذا ذهب بياخذ جماعته معه وانتم
تواجه النار في سوريا رح رح اقول محمد
مقروف اشترى جزيره بروسيا ما بتعكم كلكم
محمد مخلوف اشترى جزيره بروسيا ما
بتينك اذا اشترى او ما اشترى انا اقول لك
ان التبشير بالمز قد توقف منذ 800 عام لا
نريد
مزس ما بدي
الدين
انسانيا مشاهدي الكرام هل تعتقد ان ال
الاسد يستخدمون العلويين وقودا للبقاء في
السلطه
93.6 نعم 6 لا لم يبقى لنا اشكر يفينا
الدكتور وفيق ابراهيم والسيد وحيد صقر
نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك
الحين وفيصل قاسم يحييكم من الدوحه الى
اللقاء يعطيكم
[موسيقى]
العافيه